estaciones de servicio sin combustible y
largas filas de espera en las que siguen
teniendo gasolina desde hace varios días
las consecuencias comienzan a hacerse
sentir para Los profesionales
soy artesano independiente me hace
perder un cuarto de hora 20 minutos en
la estación de servicio Es
verdaderamente complicado
según el gobierno cerca del 20% de las
estaciones de servicio están siendo
impactadas por la huelga de los
trabajadores de total energis y eso el
bloqueo afecta también el funcionamiento
de algunos hospitales en Marsella es
difícil abastecer los vehículos de
transporte medicinal a veces llegamos a
una estación de servicio y finalmente no
hay gasolina entonces debemos hacer una
fila para nada y toca Buscar una
estación en la que sí haya combustible
una situación crítica para algunos
pacientes que sin este tipo de
transportes no pueden cumplir con sus
citas médicas
algunos de nuestros pacientes son
pacientes que tienen cáncer que tienen
citas para quimioterapia Y
verdaderamente cuando uno se pone en su
lugar sabes que genera grandes problemas
la falta de combustible también preocupa
los agricultores en macco no estuvo en
el norte este trabajador tuvo que
abastecerse en el extranjero para no
impactar la recolección de remolacha
fuimos a Bélgica para poder abastecernos
porque si no hubiésemos tenido que parar
hoy al mediodía el precio tiene un gran
impacto es un 25% más
este viernes Emanuel llamó la
responsabilidad de cada persona mientras
que la primera ministra Elizabeth pidió
a los grupos petroleros esfuerzos
salariales
hago un llamado a la dirección y a los
representantes de los asalariados de
estas empresas asentarse en la mesa y
encontrar un camino que no penalice a
los franceses
por ahora la dirección de Total energys
no cuenta con volver a la mesa de
negociaciones antes del 15 de noviembre